[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW ELLIOTT:
Thank you very much.
Thanks.
Yes.
Yes, I'm-- I'm Andrew Elliott.
And I've worked
all my life in jobs
that have required a
certain degree of numeracy,
so a lot of stuff in IT, a
lot of stuff in insurance.
And I've always regarded
myself as a numerate person.
And I suppose this whole project
came about from frustration
at seeing the way numbers
are handled in the media,
and in politics, and in
public life in general.
And it seemed to me that it sets
your teeth on edge sometimes
some of the stuff you hear
and you read in the way
that numbers are handled.
And sometimes it's
matters of subtlety
in the way in which the
things are presented.
Sometimes it's very, very basic.
Sometimes it's just a question
of people not understanding
what the scale of a
certain problem is.
And small issues get magnified.
Large issues get minimized.
And it got me to thinking that
sometimes the question that
just needs to be
asked and answered
is, is that a big number?
And so I, as one does these
days, I set up a website.
And the website had
one function only.
And that is it's a
single input field.
You can type in a number and
press a button that says,
is this a big number?
And it goes and it compares
it to a whole bunch
of reference numbers that
it's got in a database.
And it comes back
and says, yes, it's
10 times the diameter of
Jupiter or something like that.
All it does is it goes
back, retrieves the number,
and brings up some pleasant
entertaining comparisons.
But doing that work made me
think about the way in which we
regard numbers, the way in
which we relate to numbers,
the way in which we understand
numbers and big numbers
in particular.
And thinking about
it, I started writing
some of this down, and hence
the book which you see here.
So today is all about numbers.
It's not maths.
It's about numbers and
the way in which we think
about and relate to numbers.
I mean you guys, Google,
you're the masters of big data.
But today I want to talk a
little bit about what you could
do with just a
little bit of data,
and not with high tech
processing of data
but just the stuff that
you've got in your heads,
just thinking about
numbers, and thinking
about how we relate to numbers,
and how we understand numbers.
So how numbers help us
understand the world.
Now you may think I'm
being metaphorical there,
but I'm not.
I'm going to start off
by literally talking
about the size of the Earth.
And I was always told that
when you do a talk like this,
you start with the
ancient Greeks.
Well, there's your ancient
Greek Eratosthenes.
Now you may know him
because of his connection
with prime number.
Eratosthenes had a simple
way of filtering out
the compound numbers leaving
behind only the prime numbers.
But he was much more than that.
He was, in fact, the third chief
librarian at the famous library
of Alexandria.
And put yourself
in his position.
He's there.
This is a relatively
recent institution
being founded
after the conquests
of Alexander the Great, 200 BC.
The scope of the
world- his world
has expanded because of this.
And he's dealing with
new information coming
in from all over the place.
And he's trying to
assimilate this information.
He's trying to manage it.
He's trying to pull it
into a form of a framework.
He's trying to aggressively
collect this information
and deal with it.
Does that sound familiar
at all to you guys?
So there he is.
He's running the
Library of Alexandria.
And he's trying to make
sense of the world.
And he's using
numbers to do this.
Now that's a map
that he made, or it's
a reproduction of a map that
he made, of his known world.
And he's known as the parent
of scientific geography.
And while we may
look at that map
and think that's a
little bit dodgy,
it represents only about an
8% of the globe as we know it.
And it's seriously deficient
when you get down to the south.
You'll find that that word
over there on the bottom
says equator.
And he runs out at round about
India over to the right there.
And let's forget about
what's going on to the west.
But that was his known world.
But there's a lot that's
going on there that's right.
So you can see around
the Mediterranean basin
there are some familiar
shapes there, this stuff.
I mean, put yourself
in this guy's position.
He doesn't have surveys.
He doesn't have
telecommunications.
measuring devices.
He's building this from stories.
And the thing that
he introduced here
are these lines of
latitude and longitude.
So what he's doing
is he's using numbers
to put these things
into the right place.
Now the two points that are
particularly of interest here,
that's where he is in Alexandria
there on the Nile Delta.
And down below,
down south there's
a place called Syene,
which is, if you
can read the word
that says tropic,
it's on the Tropic of Cancer.
And that means that that, on
the summer solstice in Syene,
the sun would have
been overhead.
So that is what he used
to measure the earth.
Now that's not Eratosthenes.
That's Carl Sagan.
But he's showing you the
technique Eratosthenes used.
So you can see they're in
Syene there is a column.
And there in Alexandria
there's a column.
Now when the sun is
directly overhead
in Syene on the summer solstice,
the column casts no shadow.
The sun shines directly down
a web shaft-- a web shaft--
a well shaft, whereas
in the same day,
in Alexandria, there is a
shadow that's being cast.
Now this is because of the
curvature of the earth,
of course.
And that let him calculate
the size of the Earth.
Geometry.
Of course, it comes
from the Greek.
Everything comes from the
Greek-- well, not everything.
But it's a measurement
of Earth or land.
So he's measuring the earth.
The unit he's using
are feet, podes.
And if you like foot
traces, a stadion
was the length of a stadium.
And it's around 200
meters in today's terms.
And he had a measurement
there from Alexandria
to Syene of 5,000 stadia.
If I look on Google Maps, I
see that's approximately 850
kilometers.
So you can get the equivalency.
And of course, we understand
geometry in a different way
as well, as shapes,
and scales, and sizes.
And so there's a bit
of geometry for you.
There's some parallel lines
coming in, the rays of the sun.
In the southern
location in Syene,
you can see that it's falling
directly in line with a column
there.
Up in Alexandria, there's
a shadow being cast.
And if you remember your
geometry from school,
that angle there must be
the same as the angle there.
So if he measures the
angle in Alexandria,
he can work out what
proportion of the circle
of the earth that represents.
And he measured it to be 1/50th.
Multiply the two
together and you've
got 250,000 stadia, in our
terms about 42,500 kilometers.
Now that's pretty accurate.
For the time, and
for the techniques,
that's very accurate.
And there are a couple
of things I just
wanted to point out here.
One is that he's using very
simple mathematics to do this.
There's only a few data
points that he needs.
Secondly, he's
got a big picture.
He's got a view of
what's going on.
He's got a concept of
what's going on here that he
can put those numbers into.
And the third thing
I want to mention
is quite a subtle
point in a way.
We saw his map of the known
world, 8% of the globe.
So that was all that
he knew about in terms
of places, and peoples,
and things like that.
But he also knew that the
world was that much bigger.
So he knew how much
he didn't know.
And I think that's
an interesting thing
to think about.
Now we jump forward
some 1,600 years
to a fellow called
Toscanelli in Florence.
He's also an astronomer.
He's also a mathematician.
He's also geography.
He was one of the guys
behind the development
of the mathematical theory of
perspective in the Renaissance.
He was involved in the building
of the Duomo in Florence.
And he's also dealing with
a flood of new information,
because this is after Marco
Polo's voyages to the Far East.
And in fact, he spoke
to the first merchant
after Marco Polo, a guy
called Niccolo de Conti.
And he got stories
from this guy.
And he was also trying to
assimilate this information
and pull it together.
And he too made a map.
And when he looked at his map,
and when he thought about this,
he was convinced that you could
reach east by sailing west.
And guess what?
He sent that map to Columbus.
And it's a map that
Columbus relied upon.
Now there in orange you can
see what his map looked like.
And behind it you can see
what the reality looks like.
And I think you can
see the problem.
He thought that the ocean
between Europe and the east
was about 130
degrees of the globe.
In fact, it's about 210 degrees.
There was a whole
chunk of Earth that
was missing as far
as he was concerned.
And of course, the
rest is history.
Columbus ended up
in the new world
as he thought of
it at that time.
And in fact, that's
what Toscanelli wrote.
The ocean to be
crossed is not great.
Therefore by bringing
up at Antilia
the Asiatic character
is easily reached.
Well, numbers make a difference.
Yeah.
So Eratosthenes around 40,000.
Toscanelli and Columbus we're
working to around 30,000,
25% difference.
Now it's easy to
romanticize this and think
of the wise old ancient being
the guy who got it right.
But you've got to admit there's
some dodgy numbers floating
around there, the 5,000
stadia exactly, the 1/50th
of the globe exactly.
You know, maybe
he had got lucky.
But still he got the right
answer, or something close
to the right answer.
So there's that to be said.
Now if we look at what the
actual measurements are,
we get two numbers there,
one around the equator, one
over the poles that
are slightly different,
but they're both very, very
close to 40,000 kilometers.
And you may think, well,
that's a bit dodgy.
That's a bit close
to a round number.
And of course, you'd
be absolutely right.
And that comes from
the original definition
of the meter, which is one
ten millionth of the distance
from the pole to the
equator along the line going
through Paris, of course.
And now we start
getting into numbers
that are not to
do with body parts
and how long you can walk.
You're talking about measuring
the globe and a numbering
system that's derived from
scientific measurements.
And we start getting into what
we might call big numbers.
I'm just going to
take a moment now
to think about what do
we mean by a big number.
What makes a big number?
40,000 kilometers around the
world, 350 million, a number
we've heard about a lot
in this last few years,
but very seldom is it
asked, is that a big number?
7 and 1/2 billion
people in the world.
Is that a big number?
And I think there's a gap in
our society in our understanding
and the way we think
about numbers here.
So we go to school.
We learn about numbers.
We learn to count.
We learn about bigger
numbers that that.
We go into hundreds.
We go perhaps into thousands.
We become very
familiar with numbers
in a fairly limited range.
And there's an example.
Highest ever single innings test
cricket score, 952 runs for 6
declared.
That's India versus Sri
Lanka, Colombo 1997.
And I can imagine that
number building up.
I can imagine sitting
and watching that match.
And there'd be a six,
and there'd be a four,
and there'd be a
couple of singles.
And slowly that number
would accumulate.
I can grasp that process
that takes me to that number.
But it's almost
slipping away from me.
It's almost slipping away.
It's a big number
in those terms.
And now you have,
on the other side,
you have these young
scientists working in the lab.
And for them, a big number
may be a very different thing
entirely.
They may be thinking or taught
about Avogadro's number,
6.02 times 10 to the
23, the number of moles,
the number of carbon-12
atoms in 12 grams of carbon.
That's a very big number.
600 billion trillion.
And when I start saying
billions and trillions,
I've got to be careful
not to trip over my words,
because this is where
confusion comes in.
And of course,
the scientists use
that notation,
scientific notation.
And that's fine.
They learn those techniques.
They learn those algorithms
for working with those numbers.
And everything is fine.
But not everybody
thinks in those terms.
And not all numbers are
expressed in those terms.
And in between those
two, there is a gap.
And we're talking about numbers
that relate to government,
numbers that relate to
corporations, and resources,
and populations.
And these numbers are
beyond the thousands.
They're into the millions,
billions, trillions.
And you know, I have to
watch myself even now
talking to you not
to say billion when
I mean million or trillion.
And it's confusing.
And I don't think any of
us really grasps numbers
very well in that gap.
We've got a good understanding
of small numbers.
We've got techniques for
dealing with very big numbers.
But those are only techniques.
It's not really a relationship
with those numbers.
But in the middle, there
are some important numbers.
They're important because we're
called upon to make decisions
based upon those numbers.
So what I'm going to do
today is really try and just
focus on one of those
numbers, the global population
there, the last
of those, and just
try and bring that to life
for you in a simple way.
We're going to start by
saying how big is a billion.
Well, we all know
how big a billion is.
It's a thousand million
since 1974 in this country.
You know, 10 to the
9, 1 with nine zeros,
however you want to out it.
We all know what a billion is,
but can we imagine a billion?
Can we conceive of a billion?
We're going to get there.
We're going to start with
how big is a thousand.
I wanted to make this
come to life for myself.
So I phoned up my
kid at university.
And I said, can I
play with your Lego?
And I started
building a Lego strip.
There you go.
That's the start of it.
10 yellow, 10 white,
trying to build a strip
1,000 Lego studs long.
Two wide, of course, because
that's how Lego comes.
And there it goes.
I'm going from outside
the house, into the house.
You can see my toe sticking
into the picture there.
And so I go.
And so I build that strip.
And you can see
right in the middle
there I put a little red
brick just to mark the point.
There is another view of it.
Now forgive me
for flogging this,
but I'm just trying to
put this in context.
I'm just trying to give you a
visible idea of what a thousand
looks like compared to one
in-- a 1,000 to one ratio.
And there's the whole thing.
And as you can see,
I've numbered that up
to prove it to myself.
And there's a little brick
in the middle to show you
the one compared to thousands.
Now it's also the length
of the River Nile compared
to the Oxford, Cambridge
boat race, 6,800 kilometers
versus 6.8 kilometers.
It's also the height
of Kilimanjaro compared
to a pole vault record.
It's also the height
of Niagara Falls
when measured in pool balls.
So just trying to give
you some feel for--
a 1,000, we treat it so lightly.
We dismiss it so easily.
But it's actually
quite a big number.
If you look at your
screen, one in 1,000
is maybe one or two
pixels across your screen.
A thousand is a big number.
But we're going to build
up to a billion now.
To build big, we
need to start small.
So we're going to start
with a tiny little ant.
It's just a four
millimeter ant there.
And that's our starting point.
But we're going to now
need to step to something
a little bit bigger.
Maybe we want a Beetle.
And there's your Beetle.
And just luckily that happens
to be about 1,000 times bigger
than the ant here.
So imagine a thousand ants lined
up alongside that Volkswagen
Beetle.
Now in another step, what's
going to be 1,000 times bigger
than a Beetle?
Well, it turns out that Central
Park isn't a bad choice.
Just over four kilometers.
And very conveniently,
it's set in a place
where they number the streets.
So there are 50 street
blocks there from--
what's the time?
60th to 110th Street.
That makes 80 meters per block.
And you can imagine 20 Beatles
on each block of New York
bumper to bumper jammed up all
along Central Park West there.
A 1,000 cars.
And perhaps you can
imagine each of those cars
has got 1,000 ants next to them.
So now you've got a
million ants going there.
OK.
So far, so good.
What's 1,000 times
bigger than Central Park?
Turns out Australia
is not a bad guess.
It's just over 4,000
kilometers east to west.
Google Maps coming
to our rescue there.
So that's 1,000 Central Parks
stretching across Australia
coast to coast.
It's a million beetles.
And it's a billion ants.
So a billion ants
to cross Australia.
But I can't resist going
one step further and closing
the circle here.
Because if we know that
4,000 kilometers is
the width of
Australia, we also know
that 40,000 is the equator.
So 10 billion is
going to take you
a line all around the
world circling the earth.
A little deviation here.
How fast can we
circle the earth?
Now I don't know how good
your literature knowledge is,
but there's an
itinerary from a book.
And we're going from the London.
We're going via Hong Kong.
We're going via San Francisco.
We're ending up back in London.
And the giveaway, of course,
is the title there of 80 days.
So this is the planned
itinerary in Jules Verne's book
"Around the World in 80 Days."
That's how Phileas Fogg
planned to get around the world
and how he calculated that
he could make it work.
I found a map of the
route that he took.
And two things that are
interesting about that to me.
One is that it's by no means
a straight line or even
a great circle.
He's having to do a fair
bit of zigzagging especially
around about
Southeast Asia there.
And secondly, it's
actually almost entirely
in the northern hemisphere.
So the southernmost point
there is Singapore, which
is pretty much on the equator.
And so for two reasons.
Well, there's two
counteracting forces here.
One is he's going
longer than 40,000,
because he's going in zigzags.
And he's going shorter
because he's actually
only going in the northern
part of the earth.
So again, Google Maps
came to my rescue.
I measured the point to point
distances on key points there.
And actually it comes out not
far off, 38,000 kilometers.
So I reckon that was all right.
So he could do around
the world in 80 Days.
Steam and rail were what
is driving him there.
Now Eratosthenes
would have known
that you could walk around
the world in about 1,000 days
if you had a road, of course.
We can drive a bit
faster than that.
Last year a fellow
called Francois--
I can't think of
the surname now.
A French sailor did a
trip around the world.
Gabart.
Francois Gabart did a trip
around the world in a trimaran.
It took him 43 days to
go around the world solo.
A commercial flight, you
can do it in 2 and 1/2 days.
And I checked up on this.
You can take Air New
Zealand from London
to Auckland via
Los Angeles, then
2 and 1/2 hours on the
ground in Auckland.
And you can take a BA flight
back via Sydney and Singapore.
And it takes you exactly
60 hours, 2 and 1/2 days.
A plane has actually--
a B-52 bomber
has actually flown around
the world in 42 hours,
refueling on flight.
The fastest plane that's flying
is the Blackbird recon plane.
It didn't actually
go around the world.
It did a 24,000 kilometer
journey, 60% of the way,
in about 10 and a half hours.
So that would have been
equivalent to getting around
in 17 and 1/2 hours.
And the International
Space Station, of course,
goes around about every hour
and a half, so about 15 times
a day.
But then I came across
one more measurement
that I couldn't leave out,
which was from Shakespeare.
And he said that
he-- he has Puck
say in "Midsummer
Night's Dream,"
"I'll put a girdle round about
the earth in 40 minutes."
And when I saw that 40,
it chimed with my 40,000.
So there's 1,000
kilometers a minute,
one mega meter per minute.
I think we should have a new
unit of speed called a Puck.
A mega meter per minute.
Anyway, that's a
bit of diversion.
Let's talk about the
number of people,
the 7 and 1/2 billion people.
Now you guys, I'm sure, will
know all about this guy called
Hans Rosling.
Died sadly last year.
A Swedish doctor,
statistician, talker, thinker.
Wonderful fellow.
If you've not seen his
videos or read his book
"Factfulness," go
out and get it.
It's a fantastic book.
And this is him talking
about the world's population.
And in the first
picture there, he's
showing 7 billion people
as he had it at the time,
and the age distribution
of these people.
So you've got two billion
people under the age of 15,
two billion children, 2
billion in the next tranche
up to the age of 30, and
then a billion, a billion,
a billion going up to 75.
And he's talking about the
way in which population grows
and the way in which
it's a predictable thing.
And he says what's happening now
is that the number of children
is not significantly
increasing in the world.
What's happening is that
people are getting older.
And so those columns
are growing upwards
but the whole structure
is not getting wider.
So he's taking it there
from 7 to 10 billion
by aging those young people.
And that is the change that
we're seeing in the world.
And that is the way that the
population is progressing.
And he takes a
little bit further.
And he says, yes, people are
going to be living longer.
And he's putting
another block on top
there to make it
into 11 billion.
And that would cover
the age 75 to 90.
This is obviously in very
crude and simple terms,
but nonetheless it helps
you to focus the mind.
It helps you to think
about these numbers.
In the background there,
he's got a little chart
based on the United
Nations projection.
And he talks about having
reached peak child.
In other words,
for several decades
now, the number of
children in the world
hasn't been increasing.
What's been happening is that
adults are getting older.
More people are
living to old age.
And I mean there's
a whole discussion
to be had here and
of the implications of this.
I just want to pick
out one thing here.
And that is around 2050, around
the middle of the century,
we are going to pass the
number of 10 billion people
in the world.
Whether we go beyond
that, whether it be--
whether it tops out,
we're not talking
about that here now, just a
question of, at some point, we
will hit 10 billion and
what will that look like.
Now we've already got a
reference point for this.
We've already covered
this, because we know
what 10 billion ants look like.
The 10 billion ants wind their
way around the world once.
Now I need a bit more
space than an ant.
If an ant gets 4 millimeters,
maybe I need a meter.
So a line of people would
then be 250 times as long,
would wind around
the Earth 250 times.
Can we visualize that?
Let's take some Central Parks.
If we put 10,000 Central
Parks around the world,
Central Park is
850 meters across.
That's enough
space for 250 lines
of people to have three
meters between them.
And that would be 1 billion
people sitting in each park.
So one million people in
10,000 parks around the world.
Is that realistic?
Well, yes.
I'm showing my age here,
but 1981 Simon and Garfunkel
reunion concert.
They pulled 500,000 people onto
the great lawn in Central Park.
And they've had bigger
crowds than that since then.
So there we are pushing
towards a million people
in Central Park.
Is that realistic?
Yes, it is to think about that.
Do our numbers agree?
Yes, they do.
Just a few validity checks.
We were happy that we're in the
right order of magnitude here.
How dense are those people?
It works out to about
300,000 square kilometers
in that situation.
Now, obviously, we're
not going to say
that all the people in the world
can accumulate at that density.
But how densely can people live?
Well, the place on the earth
with the greatest population
density is Macau,
the sister city
to Hong Kong on the
Chinese Sea there.
And they've got 21,000
people per square kilometers.
That's only 15 times as
much as those poor fellows
in Central Park had.
So it's pretty dense.
But you can see there is
some green space there.
It is a working
city, a viable city.
It is a viable way of living.
So let's just do a thought
experiment here and say
what happened--
what if all the world lives as
densely as they did in Macau?
How much space would that need?
Well, 480,000
kilometers squared.
Now you can see what
I've done there.
I've factorized that into my
favorite number, 40,000, by 12.
So you can imagine that as
being a ribbon city stretched
around the world only
12 kilometers wide.
So think about
this for a moment.
Even from the center of that,
you could walk six kilometers--
what's that, two hours' walk?
And you'd get to the
edge of the city.
And there would be nothing
between you and the pole.
Of course, there'd be farms.
There'd be everything that
we need to sustain ourselves.
But in terms of people, we
could put everybody in the world
into a 12 kilometer wide
strip around the world.
But, of course, we don't want
to live at that level of density
that they live in Macau.
You know, for good
or for bad, we've
chosen to live in England
where the density is about 420
per square kilometer.
So that's about 50
times as much space
as the inhabitants
of Macau have.
And those 10 billion people
would need around 24 million
square kilometers.
And again, I'll factorize that.
40,000 by 600.
And so we get--
it's a belt nation there.
So a country, it's about
the same north to south
as the length of England.
It's about the same as Ecuador,
which is on the equator.
And again, that would
have space for the lake
districts, and the national
parks, and the cities,
and the suburbia, and no
more than 300 kilometers,
half a day's drive
to get to the edge.
Nothing between
you and the pole.
Now I'm not going to suggest
this is a practical plan.
But it's just to get
these ideas in your head
of how much space it takes up.
Here's another way
of expressing it.
80% of Africa.
Everybody in the
world could live
in that living at the density
that we live in England.
Of course, I'm oversimplifying
like crazy here.
And 10 billion people.
Is that a big number?
Well, of course it is.
Does the world have space
for 10 billion people?
Well, of course it does,
but that's not that simple.
We've not talked about
distribution of people here.
the food that they
need, the water they need,
the waste they produce,
what is needed to give those
10 billion people meaningful
and fulfilling lives.
Really, I'm not here to tell you
that 10 billion people is not
a problem.
Of course it is.
There are massive problems.
But until we start
measuring the problems,
they are very hard to deal with.
Unless you can actually
start putting numbers
to some of those
ideas, you don't
have a chance of actually
dealing with any of the issues.
And I like that quote
from Isaac Asimov.
Great science fiction writer.
"If knowledge can
create problems,
it's not through ignorance
that we can solve them."
So what solutions that come,
where will they come from?
When we talk about the
10 billion people and we
think in terms of problem,
but 10 billion people
is also 10 billion minds
to think of solutions.
It's also 10 billion
people with inspiration,
with determination, with drive.
And it's people like you where
those solutions will come from.
It's smart people.
It's people who are practical,
are problem solvers.
It's people who--
I think it comes down to
people who are numerate.
Those are the
people who are going
to get to grips with the
issues and deal with them.
Yeah.
And it's not just the techies.
It's not just guys like you
who can grasp the problems
and deal with them.
But there needs to
be a political will.
And the people with
political power and people
with financial power
also need to be on board
to make these things happen.
And they need to be persuaded.
And they need to be persuaded
sometimes not through big data
but sometimes
through little data,
sometimes through little
points that they can focus on,
that they can latch on to, that
they can rest in their minds.
And it's this communication
aspect, I think,
that is very important.
You know, the reporters and
the journalists of the world,
they like to sensationalize
things sometimes.
And it's a question of
trying to ground these
and trying to bring these
issues to a measurable level
to where we can
think about them.
And sometimes it's complex.
And sometimes it's simple.
Sometimes it's as simple
as asking the question,
is that a big number?
And really that simple
question is what's
behind what's in the book.
I talk about various
ways of getting numbers
in perspective-- how
do you compare numbers,
ways of thinking about numbers.
There's lots of
visualization in there.
There's stories about numbers.
And it's a question of getting
our brains around and being
able to express those numbers
in ways that are meaningful
and those that are
useful to people.
And yeah.
So there we are.
That's the book.
There's a website,
isthatabignumber.com.
And AndrewCAElliott.com.
I've also got a
Twitter feed there.
And those of you who've
picked up a copy of the book,
I hope you enjoy it.
And if anybody got any
questions, I'm happy to answer.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You say it's important
to get a grip of numbers,
and understand and put them
into relation, big numbers
especially.
How do you suggest
we help people
do that, because lots of
people, probably all of us,
struggle with very big numbers
and putting them in relations.
ANDREW ELLIOTT: I
mean, I talk through
in the book various techniques.
The top one there, landmark
numbers, is one that I think
is very important.
What I mean by landmark
number is something
that sticks in your brain.
You don't set out
to memorize it,
but it sticks in your
brain as a reference point.
And I hope that all
of you will leave
knowing that 40,000 kilometers
is the length of the equator.
And that can be a
reference number.
So when you see that, you may--
Australia is 1/10 of that.
Africa north to south
is one fifth of that.
It becomes something
that's in your head that
is a ready reference
for you to relate to.
And the 7 and 1/2 billion
people in the world.
These are numbers which, if
you have them ready to hand,
they help you to
make these yardstick
comparisons against things
that you hear about.
And it may be budgets.
It may be populations.
It's stuff that when you hear
something on the news, you say,
hold on a minute.
That's not a big number,
because it compares
with that number in this way.
And that's one of
the techniques here.
AUDIENCE: You were saying
that on your website
you have like a database
of numbers you compare to.
ANDREW ELLIOTT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell
us what some of them are?
I assume one is the 40,000.
ANDREW ELLIOTT: Yes.
Well, they come from all
sorts of things really.
I mean, what I tried to do
is to find numbers that would
make meaningful comparisons.
So some of them are just routine
household or everyday objects,
like the size of a Post-it note.
Some of them are
things like landmarks,
the height of the
Empire State Building,
or the height of the Eiffel
Tower, or something like that.
And one of the things that is
on the website and in the book
is I try and find pairs
of those numbers that
compare in an interesting way.
So for example, the Empire State
Building is 5,000 Post-it notes
high almost exactly.
I do the comparison
to within 2%.
And you get some really
interesting numbers
that come through.
And this has an
interesting function,
because it makes you think
about the numbers themselves.
But it's almost like a triangle.
Here's the Empire
State Building.
Here's a Post-it note.
And here's the number 5,000.
And it gives you a
little bit of a feel
for each of those
points of the triangle
when you think about them
in that relationship.
Of course, it means
nothing in terms
of if there is a
conspiracy theory here
that they've designed it
to fit the Post-it note,
but it's still something
that sticks in the mind.
And that's an interesting
way of going about it.
But, yes, the numbers
on the website
are things like the length of
the Nile River, the population
of Brazil.
There are numbers that
you can compare things to.
That may or may not be
intriguing when you see them.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the
talk and the book.
So it seems that
most of the things
you've talked about,
at least so far,
I don't know if in
the book there's more,
but it's like about
physical quantities.
And you can compare like
look at one versus the other.
Do you think that
the same strategies
apply to things that are more
immaterial like information
and so on?
Like maybe a few years ago
like thinking in megabytes
would have been fine.
Now we're talking gigabytes.
Maybe it's a different-- like
it's almost like unbounded
in a way like the
amount of numbers,
the size of the numbers
that these things require.
ANDREW ELLIOTT: Yeah.
So the first book
of the book is more,
as you say, physical
things around us.
It's weights and it's
measures and things like that.
Second half of the book firstly
gets into certain numbers
from science.
So we talk about how
you can visualize
or start to grasp,
for example, the size
of the observable universe.
You know, get there by stages.
And there's a chapter
on information.
And we go into things like
how do you measure information
at all, how much information
is contained in the text, how
much information is stored
in physical devices,
and things like that.
Of course, that part of
the book is out of date
before it's published.
But nonetheless, in the sense
that the principles remain.
And then there's a chapter on
mathematical numbers as well.
It's really not a
book about maths,
but we have to touch on things
like explain that infinity
is not actually a number
on the number line,
or you'll talk about
Graham's number, which
is an interesting-- you
know Graham's number?
AUDIENCE: The name.
ANDREW ELLIOTT: Yeah.
I mean, it's a number.
I first came across it
when it was in the Guinness
Book of Records as the
largest number ever used
in a serious
mathematical context.
OK.
So Graham's number
is just a recipe
for taking powers of numbers
an unbelievably large number
of times.
You could not write
down Graham's number.
The universe would
not have space for it.
So the question is, is it even
a number if all that it is
is an algorithm for
doing computation
that you could never carry out.
But actually even if
I go and buy a coffee,
and it cost me two pounds
50, that number two pounds
50 is just an algorithm.
It's not the number itself.
There are some digits there.
And we, our heads,
have the algorithm
for turning that into a number.
So there's no point of principle
difference between the two.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
I have a question,
because, I mean, my family,
like half of the kids don't
understand math, you know.
I was fortunate to
understand it a bit.
But do you think this
like understanding
numbers should have a
bigger role in school,
because how math is
taught in Germany,
for instance, is still very
basic and very on the numbers,
rather than on what
the numbers mean.
ANDREW ELLIOTT: I think that's
an interesting thing here,
because I think maths
is a thing of beauty.
Math is an abstract
thinking skill
of subtlety and profundity.
And what we call--
I mean what I call numeracy,
of course it touches on maths,
but it is not maths.
It's dealing with numbers.
It's the way in which
those abstractions of maths
connect to the real world.
Yeah.
And I think--
I mean, I'm no teacher.
I'm no educational expert.
I can't speak with
authority on those matters.
But it seems to me that we
leave behind numbers too soon
and move on to maths.
And I think that some
of the things I've
been looking at
here suggest to me
that there's much more that we
can do in terms of what I would
call adult numeracy
or advanced numeracy
to actually think about
numbers into the millions
and billions and trillions.
And there's a shift that
happens, I mean we all,
when we start thinking--
in junior school, we're thinking
in terms of linear numbers,
in linear scales.
But truthfully, the
interesting stuff
happens when you
start looking at more
like logarithmic
scales, when you start
thinking of things in terms
of multiples of each other,
and when you--
the way to understand things
like the size of the universe,
you can't do it
if you're thinking
in terms of a linear scale.
You've got to think in terms
of orders of magnitude in terms
of powers and so on.
And I think that that
numerate thinking--
I'm not aware that that's much
part of school mathematics.
And I think it's
actually very important.
And it's very useful to
think in terms of proportions
rather than linear scales.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
again, Andrew Elliott.
ANDREW ELLIOTT: Thank you.
Thank you all for
your attention.